well I mean we work for the public if
you want to think about where the
funding comes for our research it comes
from the National Institutes of Health
which is supported by taxpayers and I
think consequently we have a real
obligation to communicate science to the
public outreach I think should happen at
every level I think that working
scientists should be interfacing with
high schools for example going into to
high school biology class rooms
communicating the excitement of their
work to students cold spring harbor lab
has a has a very strong community
outreach program something they call the
DNA Learning Center and it's designed to
bring middle school students high school
students into laboratories and expose
them to laboratory science I think it's
our obligation as scientists to to reach
out to the public in the form of public
lecture series we also have a strong
public lecture program at the laboratory
I participate in it I know that that
many of the other investigators that the
lab participate in it and I think that
that the public has to understand
science not only because they pay for it
but because science is increasingly a
part of their everyday life and to go
back to the to the discussion of
sequencing and bioethics a time will
come in the not-too-distant future when
you walk into a doctor's office and they
sequence at least part of your genome
and without a basic understanding of
biology how is the how is the general
public going to react to this how are
they going to understand what's being
communicated to them about their risk of
disease and about how their own genetics
affect their response to treatments